how are you Eddie man I'm doing great
rich how you doing today well I honestly
thought of you right away as soon as
Titans gotta texted me right away and
out cuz cuz I just remember I remember
these were you know the days when I was
on SportsCenter with Stu and then an NFL
Network started in oh three so that's
kind of on the back end of of the Titans
Ravens year and year out rivalry
it was just on it was on when you were
in a Hatfield and there's Ray Lewis on
the other side a line of scrimmage yeah
those were some nasty nasty battles math
I mean it was physical it was pure
hatred between both organizations
between us and Ray between the teams
like and but there was much respect
there as well as you can imagine and we
were when we were in the same division
in the old AFC Central oh yeah we would
see them twice
Pittsburgh twice a year Jacksonville
twice a year so it was a black and blue
division and we played them in the early
2000s we were in the same division you
knew what type of game was gonna be it
was whatever Ben you you walked into
he's gonna lock the gate lock the door
sixty minutes plus the iron fist thrown
and the last man standing was gonna win
the game and you did a lot of battle
brutal you did a lot of jawing with Ray
- you got a good story about John going
faced of grill to grill good ray oh wow
yeah I would say I think back in a while
I know in 2003 we played them in
Baltimore for the AFC wild card game I
dislocated my shoulder early in the game
and you know playing in Baltimore those
fans they get on top of you it is a buzz
saw it's a hornet's nest in there and I
just recall the fans just really drawn
at me as I went into the locker room and
I was thinking to myself there's no way
I can sit out
scanning not not this one because this
would not be the last image that having
me walking off the field and with with
the harness on my shoulder and I
remember sometime in the third quarter I
came back had the shoulder strapped up
and I had met ray on the sidelines and I
wind up getting stiff arm on I mean we
got up and got back in each other's
faces and it was just one of those
intense moments where you know like yeah
I got you you got me and we just going
back and forth and terrell suggs got
involved the rest of ravens got involved
in it was just just one of those battles
within the battle that that you you knew
you had to overcome you know was one
thing to go against the defense but it's
another thing when you have a fierce
competitor or just on the side that
wants to take you out of commission
mm-hmm
and and that's what you had to fight you
know there there there's their games
when you just go into you have to
intellectually try to be the team you
know and Vout scheme them and so forth
but then there are other teams and other
people like a Ray Lewis that you have to
prepare for completely different from a
physical standpoint an emotional
standpoint and certainly a spiritual
standpoint - in order to beat them and
it takes every bit of that to get an
edge on them or to slightly just
slightly give a competitive edge against
them to get a victory well you got them
that day in Baltimore and also in the
previous playoff though they got you
despite you scoring to put them put your
team up early but that was the ravens
championship here what was it like going
against that defense that even today
many consider one of the Great's of all
rich nowadays you know you have these
exotic defenses different looks these
athletes flying around all across the
field and you know and trying to protect
every blade of grass against the spread
and all that well the Ravens were built
covered - and that was it
- massive mountains in the middle and
Sarah GU since a madam
and a young Ray Lewis who was hungry in
the middle and they were bounty hunters
across their defense everybody could hit
everybody was disciplined and everybody
wanted to put you out of commission and
the play that defense was was difficult
because you couldn't run outside you
couldn't run inside they would did we
eat up the gaps and we had a physical
front - in terms of our offensive line
so you had to come out downhill right
now and you had to attack them there was
no other way around it you work on an
out scheme you weren't going to any of
that so was mano y mano y mano you knew
would everyone to run we knew what they
knew we'll move on a run and you had to
go in there and get it the best way
possible it was just literally by
running inside a telephone booth hey
George here and the Rich Eisen show what
was McNair like on those game days
against the Ravens ah man Steve was uh
was really the quiet type okay I
wouldn't say a whole lot he would just
let his his game speak speak for him um
but Mac was a warrior and back then you
know before he went to the race we we
couldn't stand Baltimore you know
because he knew it was going to be a
physical fight for them and you had to
you know really be on guard at all times
with Baltimore because there would hit
you you know well after the whistle and
it was okay you know I mean we were
talking about an era where you know
bounties were okay you know if somebody
got put out of commission of your career
into that day that was alright you know
that that was the goal you know said so
Steve Mac you know he played hurt he was
our leader um in a lot of those games
man you know he was not going to miss
one of those games at all if you even
with a bruised sternum or a broken toe
or his arm falling off the off of his
arm or his hand by the stretch of his
the fibers of his muscles he was going
to be out there on that field playing
you know and one of the
reasons why I called you or texted you
right away after titans made it a Titans
Ravens matchup in the divisional round
isn't just obviously some of those
memory lane stuff right here but the the
here and now the right now the 2019 and
obviously 20 of it right now for it to
be about similarly the physical nature
and having people coming out of the
backfield for both teams down hill
business decision time for the defense
taking the opponents will this is what
it was about for back then that's what I
love about this Titans Ravens matchups
Saturday it's very similar you'd have to
say in that regard right Eddie
yeah it's four grown men only that's it
and right for both teams they're both
physical the Baltimore's offensive line
is nasty
the Titans offensive line they've
matured and to being a dominant force up
front and it's going to be a battle of
wills and whoever establishes the run
will win the game you know I said this
before if Lamar Jackson is sterling 35
times they'll lose it Tannehill is
throwing for 35 times they're going to
lose it's about establishing Derrick
Henry and the offensive line for the
Titans and it's about getting that
running game continuing to go for
Baltimore and I don't know that the
health of Mark Ingram but I think that
he is really and the two other running
back to half of Baltimore they they
really get that going that that running
game is not going and Lamar Jackson is
now having to take on the brunt of the
running game and throwing the football I
think that bodes fairly well for
Tennessee is going to be difficult but I
think it'll be it gives him a better
chance of beating Baltimore slowing that
office down and getting ahead of
Baltimore on that regard and in terms of
what Derrick Henry's been able to do
Eddie George he is I mean he is he
turned 6 to them he turned 60 yard days
into 200 yard days literally in about
two to three carries you can do that no
question that's the thing earlier on in
his career he was a home run hitter and
we just didn't know if he could be the
every day on
guy that can get you the five the six
the heart to the heart one and then
break it off consistently well he's
developed into that and he had the
ultimate weapon he has a 99 yard run
under his belt he were broken off
several runs well over 50 60 yards he
could run away from defenders he can
beat you up in the middle there's
nothing that he can't do you know so for
him not to be in the talks of being a
top five running back or he's the best
back in the league nobody can stop him
when he comes downhill he plants that
foot he decides coming downhill and
attacking the defender oh it's it's it's
hell
so right now you know Derek is the best
running back in the NFL he's playing
exceptional football and the beautiful
thing is he's just now getting going
you know he's picking up steam on the
back half of the season you seen it in
the Statue seen his bodies is relatively
healthy here's a bit of a tweaked
hamstring but I think I don't think
that'll be a factor and then one but
he's been absolutely phenomenal and I
would anticipate that the Titans will
make it a priority at the end of the
season in terms of getting a deal done
with him what is it like Eddy can you
describe what's it like to get stronger
on carry 25 through 30 knowing that the
other team is not interested in
potentially stopping on what is that a
feeling like to beating Michigan without
doing that you're not getting away with
that but it is equivalent to that man in
terms of seeing this offender eyes
knowing that man you know as this game
is going on you're tired I'm just now
getting started it that's a lot of fun
that is a lot of fun where you can get a
to a defense that way when you turn a
defensive strength into a weakness in
terms of stopping the run into a
weakness for them and they did get tired
of seeing you that's what it becomes a
lot of fun yeah I mean Earl Thomas was
quoted as saying that's raised a couple
eyebrows and
area that the Patriots quote-unquote
didn't seem too interested in tacking
Derrick Henry but then reminded
everybody that there's a different
mentality with Baltimore what he said Oh
without a doubt without a doubt
Baltimore I used to call him body more
because they were bring body bags to the
stadium before opposing offenses you
know what their defense and that's that
and that that culture has been
established with Ray Lewis and that
Baltimore thousand defense and it's been
a mainstay of time so this is how you
play right in Baltimore regardless of
who's in that building or not this is
the way that they play and they they
pride themselves on that how do you
think Lamar is gonna play Eddie what do
you think you know I think he's gonna be
good I think it's going to be
exceptional the kid is just phenomenal
when you think that okay this will be
the week where he kind of comes back to
earth he just does something that's so
far out there the supernatural like this
guy's in the world of his own
and I think you know with is with having
a week off really two weeks off fresh
legs the excitement of the playoffs I
think he's gonna go out and play lights
out and I tried to understand that you
know he's gonna make plays so you have
to take away something from Baltimore
and hopefully you can push him into
making some mistakes you know throwing
into double coverage or fumbling the
football you know those things start to
play in your mind if you haven't played
ball in about two weeks and the Titans
are coming off of momentum playing in
New England they're their battle ready
whereas Baltimore they have to rev that
up again so I think earlier on you know
they can try to rattle his cage a little
bit and try to force them to mistakes
but I but I just we don't happen you
know a huge impact on the game and just
being the playmaker that is how many
plays could you give me right now hey
George you know if Marshawn Lynch can
come off the street and give you a six
yard run touchdown wise he's worth 31 I
think I can give you about five good
carries okay
five big tears at the one-yard line and
probably get you no score twice so okay
so if but how many you know how many
musicals could could could you give me
Brad now yeah
how many musicals could you give me
right now right now five plays I'm a
musical I'm going to see Hamilton
tonight with my wife so I'm probably can
do it George Washington for you okay
very good
who'd you who'd you vote for for the
Heisman years ago when I voted for
Charles would never peyton manning here
in tennessee but okay well you see
talent when you when you see it I mean
Charles was mean but he was a Buckeye at
first so you know he's from the state of
Ohio but yeah was smart he then
transferred LSU but oh I thought you
mature you really phenomenal this year
right he was just a lights out
hands-down clear-cut the winner this
year for me all right that's all the
time we have Eddie appreciate the time
there something wrong with our
connection because it's very what's the
next step from you guys you guys look
good against Alabama you close the gap
no lose by no 42 points Wow well you
showed strides of improvement against
Clemson at least you scored against him
mr. bumble was a bad that was bad the
fumble was a bad ruling after further
review taking it off the board that was
insane
but the the targeting call while in real
time it looked ridiculous
if you're gonna stop and take a look at
it I mean if he puts his head on either
side of Trevor Lawrence that's not a
flag
you know and my thing is rich how do you
take down a man that's six six 240
pounds
how would that sort of gently jump on
him and lay him down to the ground
no he uses helmet and you could I mean
look that's what that's the way things
go right now real-time no flag but hold
on him and let's stop and we can go
through slow-motion and take a look at
it you know what I mean and so out of
the game one of their best players
really threw everything off I agree with
you I hear you man
last last one for you in all seriousness
Eddie George you and and I bring this up
out of just love and respect you could
have been the MVP of the Super Bowl that
you wound up a yard short you had to you
had two scores 95 yards on that day if
you add a timeout from a 1 yard long do
you think you would've gotten it what do
you think without a doubt without a
crowd no there's no question in my mind
we've got it you ready got it jolted 1 1
1 play Super Bowl on the line
do-or-die no play action no McNair
keeping it giving it to 27 downhill at
the ramps you'd had done that no
question at all right at Kevin Carter
was he in the game or was he out of the
game Eddie I mean seriously your stat
line that day was something I mean that
was a hell of a day for you you do you
think about that often anymore no not
really you know but but not in the bad
way it was a hard loss but I was also
inspired because there's like man you
know we could get this far I know I'm
gonna come back and be in this position
again and that really inspired me to
work hard that all season and the fact
that you know we played in one of the
most memorable Super Bowls people still
remember that right it's gratifying
because a lot of times people don't even
know who won last year or two years
before or four years before that but we
played and one for the ages against a
really talented Rams team that you know
for for our purpose and it's had like
like three or four Hall of Famers on
their office
yeah you know with the hole in Isaac
Bruce and Marshall Faulk and Kurt Warner
so to do battle against them and of
course Orlando pace to the battle
against then was was phenomenal Eddie
thanks for the time always love our
chats you are one of my favorites man
and that's I'm so glad that you were by
your phone I not on Saturday I got to
get Eddie George on the show so thanks
to the timeout of doubt may call me
anytime rich
right back at you that's Eddie George
you got it that's Eddie George right
here for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 under red TV
for free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app